You never have this problem
with dogsleds.
Gun it. See if it'll go
all the way around.
Every year more people are eaten
by snowmobiles than sharks.
Fact. Half man, half machine,
it's SnowmoCop.
Looks like that son of a bitch
Jack
Frost turned this neighborhood
into one big game
of shuffleboard.
Look out lady. Watch out.
Just like a Taylor
Swift relationship.
This is actually
kind of soothing and beautiful
if you put
the right music behind it.
To be fair, putting on tire
chains is a real hassle.
You want to steer
into the wreck.
Okay that one wasn't
the ice's fault.
That driver was Asian.
Luckily the Happy Honda
Day sales event just started.
My contact fell out.
There's no way we're going
to reach the summit tonight.
I'm left with no other choice.
I'm going to have to give myself
elective LASIK eye surgery.
Why don't you just wear
your prescription ski goggles?
I look stupid in these.
They should really make
the font bigger in this book.
We're only 50 feet away
from our car.
I can hold your arm
and we can just walk back.
Why do you have
all of that?
You've got to come prepared.
One. Two.
One. One.
One.
You only get one shot at this.
Just got to stay still
for a few days.
I'm going to see the mountain
like never before.
In two to three weeks.
Wouldn't you know it,
after all I found my contact.
It was on my cheek.
A person's body should
never end up in a suitcase.
Unless she says
something really crazy.
And there aren't any witnesses.
And they can't prove motive.
Giving this a thumbs up.
Bob, just go.
Okay, there is not
a snowballs chance in hell
this is going to work.
It'd be quicker just to put him
straight into a body bag.
Dragging someone behind
pickup truck in the winter
even makes hate crimes
seem whimsical.
Sometimes it's safer just to
stay inside and do drugs, kids.
They should take the suitcase
to the airport and switch it
with one that doesn't have
a dead boy in it.
Lay lay lay. Lay down.
What hurts? What hurts?
He's crying because he's crammed
against the collapsible handle.
He's talking and he's awake.
Ouch.
Suck it up.
Your tears are going to freeze
into I'm being a pussy-sicles.
We need to get him
out of the briefcase.
I'm starting to think these guys
might not be smart.
One, that's not a briefcase.
Two, you're not supposed
to unpack someone
with a spine injury.
You guys need to chill out
with this hospital bullshit.
Yeah. No hospitals.
You don't want anybody
to know about this attempted
manslaughter you're about
to put on YouTube.
Okay is there anything funnier
than giving your friend
pneumonia?
No.
Josh, do it now.
Yeah, keep laughing
but his ghost will get you back
when you go water
skiing next summer.
Here try this.
His perfect teenage body
will be preserved for eons.
This is what that
Phil Collins song is about.
Would you know my name-